[Music]
when we're talking about how
leaders can manage emotions in times of
crisis
it's very important to first understand
what we mean by manage
and and what we don't mean managing
emotions means
let's let's say regulating emotions it
absolutely does not mean suppressing
emotions
the process of trying to suppress an
emotion um is something we can do
um for a short period of time um but not
indefinitely
it's very difficult uh it trades us it
takes a lot of energy
it can actually be counterproductive as
well the the act of seeking to suppress
an emotion can exacerbate it can
heighten it
can remind us of the fact that we're
feeling something and it can come
you know kind of roaring out at a time
so if we are
if we think of managing emotions as
seeking to regulate
emotions a couple of ways uh to address
that one is
learning a little bit more about our
emotional tendencies
how are we likely to respond in certain
circumstances
sometimes that's very tactical i know
that i'm about to go into a conversation
or situation
uh that i typically experience as
somewhat uh triggering
and and let me just you know sort of
prepare myself for that let me ensure
that my calendar is a little bit you
know uh clear
both before and after this particular
interaction if i've got a
particularly difficult conversation or
interaction
make sure i'm getting a good night's
sleep in advance things like that
there's also stuff that we can do in the
moment that leaders can do to to
regulate
and manage emotions more effectively in
the moment some of that simply
entails ensuring that we're framing the
the situation in a way that's going to
be most useful for our emotional
response
framing or cognitive appraisal uh
in the in the sort of term of art that
psychologists use relates to the the
meanings that we are assigning to a
given situation to a given set of
circumstances
you know am i assuming that this is
going to be a hostile interaction this
is going to be contentious
and if so what am i basing that on is
that necessarily accurate or am i just
making some
assumptions here um a more common term
that we use
uh in in my field as an executive coach
is mental models
you know we the mental models are
basically the set of assumptions
that we make about the world around us
to help us make sense of the world
and and navigate it more effectively
these models are largely accurate that's
why that's
you know that's how we get through the
day uh and they're less accurate in
certain circumstances they're less
accurate
under stress and can we step back and
actually say well what are my mental
models what are the assumptions and
interpretations that i'm bringing to
this situation
and if they're not useful can i reframe
the situation
and then we can take a number of steps
to build our capacity to regulate
emotion over time the cheesy acronym
that i use
in my class at the gsb is messy
mess if we can commit to a mindfulness
practice
and meditation is the single most
effective kind of tool in that regard
there are a number of other ways to
pursue
mindfulness going on a reflective walk
some forms of exercise
e4 exercise if we can get
some consistent regular physical
activity
s for sleep if we can get regular
amounts of sleep and sufficient amounts
of sleep and higher quality amounts of
sleep and
the second s for chronic stress if we
can identify sources of chronic stress
in our life and diminish them
we're going to be much more effective at
emotion regulation
in those moments when we when we need it
most
so under stressful conditions like those
that we're
living on a day-to-day basis in the
covenant 19 era
we often experience what's known as a
threat response or a fight flight or
freeze response
and and under those conditions one of
the one of the ways that manifests
itself
is this a sense of urgency the need to
hurry up
and although in certain circumstances
that's actually quite useful
because obviously we evolve this
response in a way to help us
survive the dilemma is that you know
very rarely these days
do we experience a literal threat to our
physical safety that requires
an immediate physical response you know
we often experience a bunch
experience a situation that we interpret
as a threat to our physical safety and
we
we speed up in in response to it and
that that
that speed that sense of urgency is
actually counterproductive
so the the impulse to hurry should i
think
often be interpreted as a signal to slow
down if we can train ourselves to
interrogate
that sense of urgency and ask ourselves
is is that really useful here
is it really going to be helpful here or
is it going to spur me to
potentially some counterproductive
action and remind ourselves to slow down
and assess what's happening
a little bit more deliberately we're
likely to navigate the situation more
effectively
i often work with professionals so the
leaders in my practice are going through
some kind of transitional phase and and
and we often have a negative emotional
response to endings this is kind of
reflected in
a line from an old tom cruise movie
cocktail
top cruise plays a bartender and in that
movie he says at one point
um everything ends badly otherwise it
would never end
and there's some truth to that because
uh you know endings
in some sense you know they're they're
all symbolic deaths
you know they remind us that this
existence will end and whatever we
believe about what transcends this
existence
we're very attached to this existence
and and it can be quite
um dislocating it can be uh you know
unnerving to be reminded of that ending
and yet i would suggest that our you
know our negative emotional response to
endings
leads us to kind of lean away from
endings as opposed to leading into them
and we thus miss opportunities to
practice to really
gain something from each ending and
learn something from it that would help
us prepare
for the much larger series of endings
that we will encounter over the rest of
our lives
i'm reminded of a line from nietzsche
that also seems very relevant here the
end of a melody is not its goal
nonetheless had the melody not reached
its end it would not have attained its
goal either
and i think that's true for every
experience we find ourselves in it's
true for the course that i teach
you know the end of the class is not the
point but if we hadn't reached
the end you know we wouldn't have gained
the experience it's true for the
students that i work with
you know the the end of graduate school
is not the point but if they didn't
reach the end they wouldn't have
achieved the goal and i think we can
apply that in a much larger
philosophical or even spiritual sense
to our lives obviously you know the
point of a life
is not to reach the ending and yet if we
hadn't reached the end if this
if this existence weren't finite in some
sense i don't believe that it would have
the same
sense of meaning so i believe that it's
important for us to acknowledge
the finite nature of all experience and
in some sense
you know recognize and lean into the
very uncomfortable
unnerving emotions that that stirs up in
part
because it's good practice it helps us
extract something
that we can learn from you know it helps
us learn something from every experience
that ends
in a way of preparing us for the larger
endings that are to come
[Music]
you